e
all right hello everyone welcome uh time
being 10 o'clock we'll we'll uh start
the finance committee um our chair
chairman Wier is away today because uh
his grandson's becoming a Green Beret so
he went to the
ceremony um and so uh I'm going to be
filling in and we have uh four Bill
hearings today we're not going to take
any votes these are just
uh because all of these will go to
divisions the first three will be going
to division one the last one to division
three and with that we will recognize
representative uh
welcome yeah thank you Mr chairman and
know for the record my name is Mike
Edgar um I represent Hampton in uh the
New Hampshire
house um I want to you know thank the
chairman and the acting chairman the
chairman um for uh having me here to
talk about this I uh I realize that uh
I've given this in front of a few of you
before you probably recognize some of
the wording in fact some of you have
heard it so much you probably could say
it from from heart instead of me saying
it right now but um I think it's very
important uh for the uh for the people
of New Hampshire um that regular
citizens and also the the businesses uh
that are affected by this because of the
way it affects the the potentially
affects the tax rate but uh more plainly
uh this bill uh requires the state to
pay 7 a half% of political subdivision
employer pension contributions on behalf
of teachers
police officers and
firefighters many of you know the
history of the State uh reneging on its
promise to fund a portion of the
retirement system Others May testify in
more detail in the history uh but a few
of the the low points are as follows in
uh 1967 the state encouraged political
subdivisions to join the Statewide
retirement system for teachers police
and firefighters and said it and enticed
them by saying they
40% in uh 1977 the state reduced its
contribution uh to
35% 2009 it was a complicated year
you'll see the three references there
but it finally finally went down uh to
um restored a uh State contribution of
uh uh 35% but then again a uh an
amendment was put in and that was
eliminated and went back to it went to
zero at that point you know more
2022 uh there was a bill that we put in
and uh it was effectively uh changed uh
to one year only I say effectively
because it was fairly complicated
situation where there being a a uh a
Senate Bill also involved um and again
cities towns and schools were asked to
join the state retirement system with a
promise that the state would help defay
the employer costs when New Hampshire
retirement syst system was formed in
1967 replacing four smaller separate
Retirement Systems the state contributed
40% of the total employer
costs the 75% contribution in this bill
HB
14 uh excuse me from uh 1417 was for one
year only and they actually did the uh
they're able to do it you know went
through the system and they were able to
to pay that for that in that one year um
census State riged on its promise the
political subdivisions have had to pay
for the state share of the employer cost
much of which is was downshifted to
Municipal and local property taxes the
tax rates please consider voting ought
to pass on
HB
197 to partially reinstate the promise
of the state to the political
subdivisions it would provide much
needed relief to political subdivisions
and help offset the the need for
increased property
taxes hp1 197 helps the average taxpayer
in New
Hampshire also because again businesses
especially small businesses pay uh pay
property taxes
also so um you know some uh in addition
I know it's in the past has been said
well it's up to the cities and towns to
determine what they need um and then
they they should pay for it if they need
police and fire and the amount of it
then then they then they pay for it but
I don't know how many people sitting
there figure that their towns say they
need less
police many any the towns think they
firemen less emergency
services or and again with the
complicated nature of Public public
education and all of the uh additional
things with u taking care of U special
students uh do we really need need uh
you know less support for for them um
especially with some of the rigorous
requirements that they're you know that
are getting more and more uh placed on
them so uh I hope you really consider
this this bill and and thank you for the
opportunity to uh to talk to you about
it thank you representative AER any
questions from the
committee yes representative papich mull
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for testifying and taking
questions
you've already brought up the fact that
the um costs incurred are controlled by
the you know municipalities by the
political subdivisions if this bill
passes will they have more or less of an
incentive to keep those costs
down well the cost will still be there
they just won't be paying for it all the
state will be paying for some of
it if I may quick followup yes one just
one I obviously understand that the
shift changes in terms of who pays will
that change in who pays for part of the
bill increase or reduce the incentive
for the local governments to be careful
about increasing
costs okay uh increasing cost relative
to relative to say what they are
expending today when they hire a new
firefighter does the fact that the state
would now be responsible for part of the
costs increase or decrease their odds of
hiring them or paying them more I don't
think it would uh make it so that they
wouldn't hire them right now they can't
hire the ones they want there's not
enough firemen around there's not enough
policemen
around
so uh other
questions yes uh representative Daniels
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question in the purpose of the
to in the purpose of the bill it stated
that uh in part to enhance public
education can you tell me which metric
will be used to determine that public
enhanced I uh I guess I have to see
which which reference that is but uh
public education um it would make it so
that it would be easier uh maybe take a
little bit of pressure off of uh you
know the school systems with all the
money that that they have to expend
overall that they have you know we all
know they have very large budgets and
they have really big needs between
transportation and everything else so
um I I'm not really sure what else what
else to say may you can follow up okay
thank you
okay all right thank you I don't see any
other hands so thank you very much
representative AER thank you very much
done okay thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record I'm
state representative John cluder from
Sullivan County district 6 which
comprises the communities of Claremont
and Cen and I'm here today as a
co-sponsor and in strong support of
house bill 197 first of all I want to
commend the prime sponsor representative
Edgar for again introducing this bill
it's a it's a cause which I think is
important and I frankly got involved
with spon co-sponsoring this legislation
I also worked with the late
representative renie kushen on this when
I went to a meeting of the Claremont
city council probably 10 eight 10 years
ago and this city council and our city
council sits on a on a PO well a a deis
a raised deis so if you come and testify
you sort of got to look up a little bit
and they went after me on claremont's
high property taxes in the time we had I
think the distinction of being the
community with the highest property tax
rate this is I think actually 2014 it's
a little lower now but I think we're
still in the top 10 of communities and
they said and by the way these City
counselors they're Democrats Republicans
Independents it it's not a real partisan
they were complaining to me about what
the state did the 2010 through 2014 all
the downshifting and all you know
actually going back to 2008 you know the
two you know 2009 session so there is
not uh I don't want to be sound too
partisan on this because we we had faed
some challenges but they were
complaining to me about the downshifting
and they com complained that was the the
biggest downshifting they had ever
experienced as elected officials and
citizens a lot of these people had been
in lived in Claremont a long time and
they're dedicated citizens by the way
our city councilors don't get paid
anything they do it because they love
their Community but they were struggling
to to put together a municipal budget uh
and I know they our school board the
same thing but I believe this would
would it's a modest bill it does not
return it to way it was I there a part
of me wish we could go back to the thir
35% this is a modest
72% and I realize some people said well
the cities and towns are going to learn
to live with less of a contribution from
the state but In fairness they were
encouraged to join the retirement system
in 1967 that's when I was 10 years old
and we're just starting to fact that's
the year first year I first came to the
State House on as a fourth grader but
they were encouraged to join the
retirement system and now you know and
maybe we had to do it as legislators
because of the Great Recession and the
lack of Revenue and we have to balance
our budget obviously according to house
rules but I think we should have
returned in 2012 to what we had before
because it's really hurting our
communities Claremont cin and and and
especially the area I represent but I
think a lot of people are complaining
about even the city of Lebanon which I
think is is in great shape and I hope
I'm not anybody from Lebanon when they
start complaining I think we ought to
sit up and take notice uh so this is a
modest bill but I think I urge you to
pass this bill in its present form of of
at least seven and a half% and give us a
little bit of a break and to the
question of earlier whether it's going
to encourage communities to become spend
thrifts and hire the high highest paying
police off I know in my community it'll
just re provide a little bit of relief
and it's not I don't think they're going
to go on wild spending spree and we have
in fact two other members of the house
this term are members of city council
and they can I'm sure testify they're
not here today the the the tightness of
our our city budget our school budget
it's a constant Challenge and as the
representative Edgar lud we have a labor
shortage it's hard enough to to hire
police officers firefighters teachers so
we're still going to have to struggle
but this bill will give our
municipalities our school district and
our counties and all of you are members
of County delegations and I know as
chair a few years ago we had to struggle
we had to re build a new nursing home or
renovated excuse me and the we had to
struggle and we got some aid from the
state through arpa but still we had to
bond it and it's going to be a direct
impact on the property taxpayers so I I
don't I don't know if I can answer a lot
of technical questions but I urge you to
please pass this bill and get it to the
floor at least we can have a debate uh I
think it's it's it's it's a matter of
fairness for our our community
okay thank you thank you representative
questions no seeing none thank you very
much okay thank you Mr chairman members
committee so next we have uh Marlene
I'm Marlene fryer and I'm from Bradford
New Hampshire I'm a selectman in
Bradford and the schools are having a
big big impact on on the
taxpayers uh we're having budgets right
now we're
meeting we're we're cutting everything
to the town they're
cutting money for the roads which puts
us
backwards I mean we need help we need
help our young people are not staying
because they can't afford to live
here are the seniors that have people
that have lived here all their lives
can't afford to live here they are they
are moving out it's and we really really
need it's pitting towns against each
other it's pitting people because we are
in the kiage district and we are seven
Town school so you've got towns after
each other it's it's not it's not very
nice at all um I have teachers in my
family my daughter's a school
nurse and um they go after the teachers
you make too much well the teachers need
to have a salary to live also and um
they are the
future of our Our Town our children and
we need the prices are just too high
it's pricing everybody out of out of out
of the state almost not just the town
and I'm very much in favor of this thank
you very much thanks for coming um
questions yes um representative
Ms thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in and uh speaking with us um
earlier one of my uh colleagues um asked
how um this bill would enhance public
education
I wonder if you might be uh able to
answer that question
well it it would
help it would help with the cost it
would help with teachers coming
in um you can't find enough people
police fire I mean we have a vol fire
alone let's say and that's part of
Education that helps with
everything um we were asked well do we
need any more firemen can they wear each
other's equipment I mean that's how bad
it's gotten yeah I'm not kidding you
they've asked the highway department
well if it's a snowy
day and you know it's going to snow you
stay home the day before so when you
come in for a snowstorm you don't get
overtime education is the same way do
you need Paras and special education is
is a high cost for the school systems
and it's
mandated and a lot of people don't
understand what that costs well why did
they need help maybe they all ought to
go into these classrooms my husband
taught special ed in Manchester for 30
years I have a son that teaches a
son-in-law that teaches up in uh Warner
Special Ed I mean they put their money
into things people don't understand what
teach is putting in if they're they care
about the
students um there's more or more
problems in the school like my daughter
is a school
more problems for the kids psychological
everything else and that's it would all
help with that maybe it's not much but
it's a start I mean to not do
anything to do something is better than
nothing thank you I'll just point out to
representative Ms um if you look at the
fiscal note 2third of the cost of this
bill is related to School Employees as
opposed to municipals representative
Papo V Müller has a question thank you
Mr chair and again thank you for uh
testifying and for being willing to take
questions you were describing how the
lack of State support is pitting Town
residents against each other because of
concern for high costs mhm those costs
would not change under this all we
change is the pocket that the money
comes from money would be paid from the
state but the
state because the state pays for
everything then you'd also be
responsible for paying the state share
for every other community so essentially
we're just talking about which way does
the state reach into your pockets to pay
for this can you help me understand why
in your opinion this bill would decrease
that type of uh stress in the town it
helps with the taxes from the school s
when we are going right now we're going
through budgets and they're cutting the
high CU a comes from the state we have
police we have fire each town has
teaches each town has the
schools so it does help at least it
gives people that the state is doing
something because right now the people
don't feel the state is doing anything
uh representative tillers thank you
thank you very much for taking my
question and I don't want to put you on
the spot but I'm just curious if you
have an idea um if this bill were to
pass what the town of Bradford would
receive for that 7 half% from your
retirement payment and if
so if you could equate it to some to
Cuts you've made that were equivalent
choices well one is um 200 ,000 for the
roads every year that puts you back as a
town
um that money would come in to help
reduce at least it would make the towns
people
feel it's not a lot but it's a help that
they're at least thinking of the people
that live here and work here or have
lived here all their
lives it it
if nothing else it's Goodwill to know
that your legislators are working for
you and don't care because this is what
it's like I mean we had a school meeting
where people wanted to cut $10,000 from
the school
budget and 16 almost 1600 people showed
up to support the schools it shouldn't
have to get that bad that we have to do
thank you Miss frer and we have next uh
let's see
here um Miss uh Margaret burns from
conquer from the representing the
municipal
Association good morning thank you my
name is Margaret Burns and I'm here
representing the New Hampshire Municipal
Association in strong support of house
build
197 restoration of a state retirement
contribution has been a longstanding
policy of the New Hampshire Municipal
Association which represents all
234 cities and towns in the state of New
Hampshire and we are grateful for the
continued legislative efforts to attempt
to restore some level of State
contribution to those costs for
municipalities I think that the history
of the retirement system the cuts in the
contributions has been well laid out
already so I will not Bel labor those
points here this morning we do
understand that this budgeting process
will be a challenging one however I wish
to remind the committee that in past
years the legislature has seen fit to
recommit to promises made to local
governments with respect to funding in
2021 the legislature increased the
municipal meals and rooms tax
distribution to 30% and several years
ago the legislature did provide one-time
funding equal to 7.5 % of the municipal
employer contributions while those
pieces of legislation were not full
restoration of Prior promises made they
showed a recommitment by the legislature
to local governments and their budgets
and they also significantly assisted
municipalities with budget crunches and
property tax relief by providing those
forms of relief this bill does the same
thing it would not be a full restoration
of the amount originally promised to
municipalities when they were enticed to
join the retirement system but it would
be a step in the right direction and it
would recommit and show that the state
budget and budgets decisions made at the
state level are in fact inextricably
intertwined with Municipal budgets and
Municipal property taxes we have heard
the argument that municipalities have
control over their employer costs for
the retirement system because they make
decisions about compensation as well as
hiring decisions in general however I
wish to share that the majority of the
costs that municipalities pay in their
retirement contribution is in fact the
unfunded liability on the system about
75% of what municipalities pay
represents the unfunded liability on the
system and the unfunded liability is a
result of decisions that were not made
by local government employers and over
which they have no control additional
the rising cost of retirement coupled
with Rising costs of benefits and other
things that go along with having
employees and hiring employees all
present a serious crunch on Municipal
budgets that do lead to lower
compensation or not hiring and not
filling positions that are otherwise
needed in the
municipality any state contribution to
municipalities is property tax relief
because it offsets local budgets and
local expenses
I've also submitted a letter by email to
the committee I appreciate your time
this morning and I encourage the
committee to vote a to pass on this
important piece of legislation thank you
very
much um thank you Miss Burns I'm I'm
just going to ask a question you said
75% of costs I assume you mean of
employer costs corre rather than total
contribution yes yes thank you Mr
chairman other questions from the
committee representative Daniels thank
you Mr chairman uh we have heard uh
testimony that in ' 67 the state
encouraged the political subdivisions to
become part of the Retirement System
since then has that has that been
changed to a requirement are towns
required to be part of the retirement
system in a sense yes because police
teacher and fires are teacher and fire
are required to be part of the system so
yes they are
additionally even for the group one
employees who are volunt who mun IP
alties made decisions about whether to
include in the system um and of which
most municipalities have made that
decision to include the employees in the
system in order to leave the system the
municipality would have to pay their
share of the unfunded liability which is
typically prohibitive so in a sense even
for that
group they are they are required to be
part of the system unless there's a
willingness to appropriate that money to
pay the unfunded liability okay thank
thank you representative Ms thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you for taking my
question um I'm I'm glad that you um you
you highlighted
um the uh unfunded liability and uh the
fact that um towns really didn't have
much input into what drove that could
you provide just a little bit more
detail in terms of what are some of the
things that the state did um to
artificially uh reduce the liability in
the past that we're now paying the cost
for there have been uh there's been
legislation passed to change benefits
over the years um that has that has
increased costs although the state did
make some serious changes around 2011 um
as a result to try to reduce some of
those costs but decisions with respect
to investment and management of the
funds none of that is municipally
controlled and some of that has had an
impact on the rates and the costs for uh
both the state as an employer and
municipalities and other local
governments as
employers follow uh thank you um wasn't
there also um legislative action taken
to um reduce the discount rate or or
increase the discount rate whichever one
increases the
liability get remember there have been a
variety of legislative actions that have
in fact increased the unfunded liability
theost thank you thank
you thank you oh okay representative
seaworth and followed by representative
Papa vich Müller and that will be the
last for
this thank you Mr chairman given the
focus on the unfunded liability do you
think it would as a matter of policy it
would be effective for the state to
attempt to address that and relatively
speaking given the limited ability to
find funding is that a more effective or
less effective solution than um
offsetting payments from the towns that
that is a great uh great question nh's
policy long-standing policy is to
restore some level of State contribution
um to municipalities that being said we
have supported in the past efforts by
the state to pay down the unfunded
liability the state is on track um with
its plan establish lished many years ago
to pay down the unfunded liability by I
believe 2039 so the state is on track to
do that um but yes there have been
legislative efforts to try to uh really
Target the unfunded liability as another
way of reducing costs that we have been
supportive
of thank you um representative Papa V
mull thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for testifying and for taking questions
just I would appreciate if you'd help me
reconcile two parts of your testimony
one part was that you were saying that
because of the lack of the state support
uh towns have to offer lower
compensation or even pass on hiring
decisions because they cannot afford to
pay those people and then you said that
passing this would bring property tax
relief but if the problem that we are
solving is that the compensation is too
low and they cannot hire wouldn't that
mean that they would be paying people
more and hiring more people how does
that work with the property tax relief
part I would appreciate your thoughts
yes I I really appreciate the question
sometimes when we talk about property
tax relief there's an assumption that it
means that property taxes will be
reduced that that's what property tax
relief has to mean and I I understand
the perspective however any additional
Aid or Revenue that comes to a
municipality that offsets expenses that
the municipality already has or that
offsets existing expenses and therefore
allows municipalities to invest in other
things that their constituents want them
to is property tax relief um and
that that is the fact thank you sir
thank you for coming Miss Burns thank
vone and I don't see uh which city or
thank you Mr chair I'm Mark Fone I
represent the town of eping and I'm here
to briefly speak in favor of this
bill let me just put it in very granular
terms if this bill passes um the school
$781,000
next
year we have on the district warrant a
teacher
$400,000 so the net impact on the T on
the town tax rate the school tax rate
would be actually a negative um if you
save 781 th000 and you're only spending
an extra 400,000 you still have a a net
saving of
300,000 another way to put
it if this doesn't
pass and the teacher contract passes the
tax rate goes up 40 cents on the
thousand now there's a lot of talk about
trying to keep taxes down and a good way
to do that is to vote down the teacher
contract that
happened last time we had a teacher
contract actually two rounds ago and
guess what happened in eping teachers
left and guess where they went to they
didn't just leave the state they went to
districts where they paid more
money so that's the reality here so if
districts like eing want to keep
teachers in one place and guess what the
quality of Education depends on stable
Workforce if you're constantly churning
staff then you are constantly retraining
you are constantly trying to get a a
quality out of workers who may not be
there the next year so long story short
pass this bill please so that eping
can have a good incentive for passing a
teacher contract so that we can keep
you thank you representative any
questions seeing none thank you very
much um I do not have any more pink
cards does anyone else here wish to to
testify on how House Bill
197 okay I have a uh the blue sheet has
uh three names uh in favor two of which
spoke today so um they double counted
here all right we'll close the public
hearing for House Bill 197 and open the
hearing for House Bill
97 um I don't even have a Mr chairman
yes I I assume on the blue sheet there
were no in opposition that's right there
were three names thank two of which we
heard from and okay here we have some
cards okay and I will recognize the
prime Mr chair I'm sorry yes it's not
quite 10:30 for the time I don't know if
that clock oh that clock's wrong I
apologize yeah unfortunately we we'll
have to get this fixed but that clock is
about 10 minutes slow so the actual time
is like 10:33 so back to this so um and
we will recognize um the uh Prime
sponsor repres representative Buco from
finance thank you Mr chairman for the
record I'm representative Tom buo
representing Carrol County District 1
and I am here today to introduce House
Bill 97 FN and to request that the
finance committee recommend this bill
ought to
pass some members May recognize this
bill as I have introduced similar bills
in the past and and those bills have
been successful in making the
Appropriations necessary to pay down the
delayed and deferred Waste Water Project
list also other individual bills have
been
appropriated have appropriated state aid
grant to
municipalities that have completed
expensive Wastewater projects
ideally level funding this program in
each budget and assuring that the
Appropriations on non-aps would reassure
municipalities when issuing the debt
they need to build these expensive
Wastewater
projects level funding this program
would also go a long way towards um the
governor's priority of partnering with
local communities to expand the state's
housing
the main the main thing here is even
though these these bills have been
introduced several times they they still
need to be introduced each budget
because they have to remind people that
they that um what they do and that they
need to be
funded and I at that at this point I
take
questions thank you um representative
can you remind us what happened to this
Bill last time was it was the money
already in the budget from the governor
or I don't remember I'm
sorry
um the money was in the previous
budget but it has to be re re
appropriated every time
so level funding this this program would
be much better than having to bring
these bills in SE separate individual
bills for each
list and that that's what this that's
what the 15 million is for to to to
bring that to a level funding each
year thank you questions yes
representative
Mooney thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for being here you
are missed on this row here on finance
so thank you your bill um I recall it
before and I'm just wondering in terms
of specifics of spending is there a
priority list is there a requirement
list is there projects that are um fall
under a certain criteria that would be
in line first to receive this amount of
money and how would that work thank
you yes thank you representative um that
goes through Dees and they have they
have a priority list and um so when so
when they um approve approve Pro
projects and they and they um the the
municipalities begin the projects they
actually have to complete the projects
before they before theyve appropriated
any
funding is that you come close to
answering your question that's fine
thank you
representative yes representative
rung thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um if this bill
were to pass would that also serve to
offset property taxes by providing state
revenue that otherwise the towns would
and the municipalities would have to
pick up right well the M yes the
municipalities have to have to cover the
cost so they either have they what they
end up they usually um issue bonds and
issue debt
so mun so um that that's that would have
to be covered
the questions yes representative M thank
you Mr chair and thank you uh for taking
my question um as as as a newb on the
committee please bear with me if i u I'm
asking questions that everybody else
understands um the bill references RSA
uh
486 and there are two sections in that
RSA um 4861 which deals with State
contributions in a 4863 which deals with
alternate State contributions and the
and the second section I mean
4863 specifically mention seven towns uh
projects in seven towns of which one is
Hampton and since I represent Hampton
that immediately caught my attention um
so is will this money be
used will this be money used will this
money be allocated specifically to those
seven towns or to new project project in
other
towns uh I don't believe so I believe
that what we're trying to do here is um
fund the program fund the state aid
grant program so that
municipalities know that the funding is
there but right when the funding is not
there they don't issue the debt and they
don't build the projects and and um I
there were no really specific specifics
all right thank you representative
buuk I don't see any oh I see a hand
here representative priest thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um you mentioned that there is
a
housing yeah problem in this state and
especially with towns that do not have a
public water and sewer
uh infrastructure in
place how would this bill help
them thank you
um
so
um what's what is restricting some of
the in some places the housing is is the
septic system it has to be it has to be
more
um spread out and when I heard the
governor's speech she was she mentioned
um she wanted to work partner partner
with the local communities is the way
so
um that's that's how the housing program
got put into this bill it was
it before before um
that
um didn't used to mention um housing
but the you can't you can't expand the
housing program if you don't have septic
projects thank you thank you so um thank
you very much representative um repres
we we'll go on I I don't see any other
hands thank you oh okay thank you so um
representative seaworth pointed out to
me that representative priest is a
co-sponsor of this bill and so I just
wanted to point out I believe the
correct rule is that um if you're a
co-sponsor of a bill you can be either
on that side of the room or this side of
the room and and if you're on this side
of the room you can participate and ask
questions just like everybody else if
you're on that side of the room you
could testify just like everybody
testifying you can only do one or the
other not both so that representative
priest decided to be here okay uh next
Conway thank you for that reminder also
thank you chairman aguire um I was in
the legislature 80 884 885 86 887 so I I
appreciate what you people have facing
uh I also want to thank uh
representative buo and representative
bichun for spearheading this issue for
many years many recent years I'd like to
start up a test testimony Oh by by the
way I represent lore Bartlet water
Precinct North Conway water Precinct and
I'm a policy analyst for Granite State
Rural Water Association which is
affiliated with national Rural
Water the essence of this bill um
historically is is it unites federal
grants with a state aid grant program
and makes it possible for municipalities
across the breadth of the state to fund
large wastewater treatment
projects um this bill if we found
through the years and I've been involved
since the creation of this bill that
came out of Representative Allard out of
Conway in
1992 and believe it or not I've been
involved since then um I've been working
with representative buo for 20 years on
this issue and every year we have to
come in and try to bring the new legis
legislation up to speed as to what this
program really accomplishes right now at
15 million a year it takes away those he
requirements and those low requirements
of up and down it flat lines at at a 15
million a year 15 million a year from
the state general fund leverages right
now $600 Million worth of completed
infrastructure with Bond payments
anywhere from 20 to 30 years depending
on the 20 years is usually U State
revolving Loan Fund which EPA money
coming through the Department of
Environmental Services the 30 year is
Rural Development Association money that
comes a rural development uh utility
program that comes through the uh
Farmers Bill the farm bill so it's
Federal Federal money coming into the
state uh rural development comes in
through Vermont uh they manage both
States and the allocation to New
Hampshire is $12 million a year and
every time they take some of that 12
million and use it for for Grants it
reduces on on a ratio basis the amount
of principle they can use so $12 million
a year through the national formula
isn't really enough in New Hampshire so
we fight from the local level to get our
US senators and congressmen to bring
more money into New Hampshire through
Reserve monies and we've been
able the cycle ends in in April we've
been able to go in August in the
National Reser called a pool money
territories and states that head the
allocation but didn't use it and we tap
into that and flow it back soon Vermont
into New Hampshire so that's an ongoing
process too um now I know what you're
faced with because this program is faced
with 2008 recession when they didn't pay
any on this program for a number of
years and this in the towns still were
obligated to pay so they had to pay the
states
portion recently and I like I would like
to remind you that recently this this
this uh panel here this this committee
spearheaded the idea of understanding
the program more and in the trailer bill
they clarified that this is not the de
Department of Environmental Services
money this is money passing from the
federal government through the
Department of Environmental Services to
through the EPA to make the payments on
this um so when a governor asks agencies
to cut back a certain percentages
historically that's occurred uh in the
past the agency took credit for cutting
some of this program and the trailer
Bill said no this is pass through money
not to be part of an agency CAU credit
credited to a Governor's directive uh so
they're kind of prioritized what this
money is about um and then and then they
uh we have been fighting through many
years to get that list uh representative
priest there's a list of all the
projects that had been completed
and after the projects are final finally
completed and passed on to the the DS
for certification of payment he has to
wait one year for the warranty to go out
so even after final comp completion a
project has one year before it's
certified to go to governor councel for
the actual contract to payment the list
that comes before you through the
through hb1 every year the governor's
budget coming from the agency is called
the maintenance budget and that's that's
all they put in historically and that's
what's in there this year this bill says
beyond the maintenance budget and you'll
see that in the layout of the monies is
is the need to fund it at at 15 million
that adds enough more so you've got
you're back to that level funding that
we need to to uh to have in order for
municipalities when they vote their
bonds quite often in on towns by 2/3
sometimes in precincts by simple
majority because their chatter created
by the legislature as a subgovernment
entity of the state not of the town but
of the state gives them the right to
pass bonds by just a simple majority so
there is a little bit of difference of
the challenge of taking that debt on
nobody can force those municipalities to
pass the bonds we hear all about home
rule and and where the power is the
federal government the state government
cannot force municipalities pass a bond
is in the state's interest for them to
pass the bonds on water because
everything you do now especially housing
hinges in the health of the communities
the economic viability of communities
hinges on clean drinking water and the
protection of that drinking water so
when you look at the general budget the
best place to put your money first when
you prioritize any budget is building
the infrastructure of Water waste water
that this state needs for and its
communities need when this money is
there and those people go to vote you
say this money is there it helps them
understand and pass the votes needed if
you want to if we all have to work
together just as expeditiously as we can
with everything behind this in order to
make it happen because it takes years to
design it to put it out to bid to build
it a Year's warranty and then it goes to
Governor C covor if it's certified and
all the oversight of that Ty process of
design and build all of the law in 486
says the dees has to has to oversee even
the design has to has to approve it to
go out to bid has to approve every uh
invoice has to uh uh authorize final
completion has to give up retainage and
then finally has to have all that
information come back to him so they can
certify it for payment quite a process
at the local
level funding at at $15 million a year
makes the program solid makes it easy
for everybody on this on this end of the
financial stuff then see the importance
of it and finally yeah it comes out of
the general fund but every dollar you
put into infrastructure on water and
wastewater comes back many F much F and
I can tell you in Mount Washington
Valley 400 people in North Conway water
Precinct went from from ground zero and
build $75 million worth of
infrastructure at an affordable rate
level if if if you go to um an extreme
level of rates three times the state
average so your rates are stressed you
get an extra 10% so you get 30% out of
the state aid grant so I tell everybody
at the local level put you put all the
money you can in out one pocket which is
your rates and then you can get 10% more
of the up Auto pocket which is long-term
debt and they do that because the way
they do it is they put once they pass a
bond they put all their money
immediately into design into a water
Wastewater master plan hire a consultant
find out what you want get a bond vote
on phase you build it by phases which it
takes a long time to do that uh it took
North Conway 25 years to go full bore
with a voter approval every single bond
to build out $75 million were worth the
work that money that invested money now
protects the the water m Washington
Valley it allows that the growth that's
occurring by that would have occurred
anyway uh to to uh handle all the Waters
of second homes mobile homes uh Parks uh
all the tourism Mount Washington Valley
goes from about um a population of
15,000 to 36,000 overnight it's like the
city of Rochester the money that comes
out of rooms and meals into the general
copper is is is far greater than the
money that comes out of this leverage
budget to pay it so it's a great
investment in the money you need in the
general budget I I I'm I'm sorry I went
on so long but uh I think these
reminders of all of this uh information
is critical for for new members and and
for to jump start this bill and thank
you m Mr chairman for letting me present
so long yeah you wrote down three
minutes I think it was maybe triple
representative papovich moment thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for testifying
and taking the question I'm on finance 2
and this is a finance one bill so I
really don't have a lot of background
knowledge on it I thought you had I
thought I heard you testify at the
towards the beginning of the testimony
that this is U more of a pass through
for federal funds and then at the end I
heard you say that this comes out of the
general fund could you help me clarify
my confusion and explain if this entire
Mount is bonded by the towns and they do
the projects that we hope they will how
much money will the state itself be on
the hook for out of this appropriation
balar well once they once the governor
and Council approves the the payments it
it pays 30% of principal interest on the
local debt so it's a great leveraging
because overall now that 15 million
which which you can count on being every
year even if you if few people pass it
that way make it that way um that that f
is funding right now $600 Million worth
of local
debt um and and once it goes to Governor
counil it changes a little bit because
it now instead of a promise because the
law says the state shall pay um it
becomes a contract where the state where
now the towns know that the state the
government Council has actually entered
into a contract to make those payments
for 20 to 30 Years thank you
representative
Lehman thank you Mr chairman and nice to
see you Bill so I'm a little confused
because in the past we've we've
obviously called these Buco bucks for
the new members because Tom has been
submitting this request for the at least
the last nine
terms but are these for new projects or
to pay off existing projects because in
the past we put the money forward to
meet our past
obligations but I'm hearing that this
may be for new projects
that and P obligations is that correct
that's a great question and thank you
for clarifying that yes this bill this
bill addresses the fact that the budget
that comes forward every year is a what
the What's called the maintenance budget
and the maintenance budget is paying the
obligation that's already gone to
Governor counsel for approval so to
maintain that obligated uh contract if
you will because now the process has
been completed uh as far as the state
committing to it uh you have no money
for new projects unless you put it in in
the budget and that 15 million puts it
in the budget at what is what we have
come to understand is is enough to to
fund the full budget going forward even
though the demand might go up to we have
one point the old study said we have 1.3
billion worth of need to build the
infrastructure that was before the
housing came in and recent years so I
suspect we have much much more than that
to to to build and accomplish to meet
the uh needs of the state's housing and
other protection of its Waters so this
this does put in money for new projects
and that flatlined estimate is what
we've worked with the to come to
understand is what's needed when when
you see what what actually comes in on
the next cycle the dees could could
modify that but we don't think they need
to because it it's such a cycle of
building and waiting for the oneyear
warranty and and even though it's
Project's approved the money's there
it's going to be some years before it
actually is committed by a governor
counsel for payment so that that Rhythm
seem the 15 million seems to put enough
money in now uh and and last session U
you people understood enough to put it
in for this year this is the first time
ever that we've come into a new budget
cycle with 20 with the money in the
first year 2025 the money's there for
new projects under the under the last
bill of 15 million this bill tries to
say keep it going for 26 and 27 so after
the next election two-year cycle they
come into 27 and money's if new projects
like it is now that's the first time
that I've been here and I've been here a
long time um whole person Mr H thank you
very much uh representative rang we're
going to be discussing this in division
so if you can hold your question that
would be good thank you I still have two
more cards and we're running out of time
so next we have uh Miss Burns again from
chairman good morning Margaret burns
with the New Hampshire municipal
Association here in strong support of
House Bill 97 House Bill 97 appropriates
$15 million in fiscal year 26 and 27
respectively to provide the grants for
local Wastewater projects as required by
RSA chapter 486 these grants cover the
cost of planning design and construction
of sewage disposal facilities covering
20 to 30% of these eligible costs there
is a long and storied history of
inconsistent funding that has left many
municipalities to foot the state share
over the years um dating back to uh
changes made after the Great Recession
um and really starting in 2008 more than
$50 million in the state share was
funded by municipalities over those
years lack of funding has also led to
long periods of projects that are
otherwise eligible and are ready to go
and ready to receive these grants being
placed on a delayed and deferred list
the current banial budget does include
as mentioned before $27.9 million for
the SAG grants the state aid grants for
municipalities and even included a
policy statement that it is the intent
of the legislature when adopting that
budget that state aid grants would
continue to be funded at $115 million
annually for 2026 and
2027 this bill would fulfill that policy
promise made to municipalities and to
their taxpayers many of which went into
approving these projects with the
understanding that the municipality
would receive the 20 to 30% state aid
grants that are required by RSA chapter
486 I know this committee has already
received some letters from
municipalities with projects that would
be eligible to receive the grant funding
I believe from Durham from marac um from
other from Claremont and from other
communities as well this is an important
piece of legislation for these
municipalities it shows a state and
local partnership in addressing not only
the need for Wastewater and Wastewater
upgrades but also the need for a
partnership between the state and
municipalities in supporting growth and
development which is not possible
without key infrastructure thank you so
much thank you Miss Burns are you likely
to be with us when we have this in
division one I am okay so we'll save
questions for you for that time thank
you all right and last we have uh shal
Connelly um representing RMI NH
wpca so you can tell me what that is
thank
you is that on oh yeah good morning uh
my name is Sheila Connelly and um I'm
here today in support of this bill
almost um it's not
enough honestly every one of you used a
toilet today and you might use it again
today today and that flush is our
responsibility to do something
appropriate with and folks in the um
Wastewater industry are have a trade
association called the New Hampshire
Water Pollution Control Association I've
been a member of that for more than 30
years and serve on their um uh
government Affairs committee uh the the
funding here is often overlooked and
largely because it goes away you flly
and it goes away so what I'm here to do
today is remind you that there are
people out there working every day to
make sure what you flush goes away
properly and um in New Hampshire of our
234 communities um just under a 100 have
publicly owned treatment plants and many
of those are Regional in Solutions um
have all of you toured a wastewater
treatment plant if you haven't I can
help you get there it' be really fun but
wiip pasak River Basin program was a
jewel uh that made our water Winn pasak
clean and the river so that serves 10
different communities so there are small
communities who can't do this alone
Plymouth New Hampshire I live in
holderness right across the river um
they got funding through this process
and were able to upgrade their septage
receiving so they take in septage from
30 different towns in the North Country
who do not have wastewater treatment
plants this is an essential service it's
an important thing for um business you
can't run Business Without a toilet for
your employees um it's also really
important for protecting our environment
and it goes underloved and underc cared
for um on on the financial piece of it
this 15 million gets us back to level
funding that we need to stay at for
several years we weren't getting any
funding and so as representative
leechman alluded to we got caught up now
we've made good on those obligations and
we need to continue this investment um
in Manchester some of the pipes are over
a hundred years old in the ground when
they fail it's catastrophic so we need
to invest in this infrastructure we need
to take care of it and we need to
recognize this as a priority and I thank
you all for the very difficult job you
have for coming up with the the budget
and I appreciate your hard work on
it thank you any questions for Ms
Connelly no oh yes representative Dan
thank you and I and I don't know if the
question may be more appropriate for
Miss Bur
um where this is covering uh 26 and 27
can this legislature legally Legally
bind the next
legislature uh that's a better question
for someone with a higher pay grade than
me thank you thank you very much so I'm
going to close the public hearing for
House Bill 97 and we will open the
public hearing for House Bill 246 and
recognize the prime sponsor Judy Aaron
oh just on the
97 um there were two names in favor
again one was we one one we had already
heard from um now on House Bill 246 I
have 1 2 3 4 five 6
uh eight nine in favor and two who don't
say so um plus the prime sponsor so um
I'm going to caution people to please
speak briefly and and try not to repeat
what previous um speakers have said
representative
Aon thank you so much Mr chair and thank
you so much to the finance committee for
hearing this bill
today I'm introducing this bill HB oh
first of all I'm representative Judy
Aaron from uh uh Solomon County District
4 representing the towns of aworth Goan
langon lemster and
Washington again I introducing this bill
HB 246 to you today directing the state
conservation committee to implement the
Conservation District climate resilience
grant program and making an
appropriation therefore I was requested
to file this leg legislation on behalf
of our conservation
districts it would appropriate General
funds of 50 ,000 in fiscal year 26 and
$50,000 in fiscal year 27 to the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food to be distributed by the state
conservation committee to the 10 County
Conservation districts to implement a
Conservation District climate resilience
grant
program so why should we do
this in
1945 New Hampshire RSA 432 was
established and they established New
Hampshire's conservation districts to
set local priorities and to deliver
information and assistance to land
owners and users over the next year 10
County Conservation districts were
established in 2021 New Hampshire passed
the healthy state soil Bill the state
has already made a commitment to invest
in the state's soil Health soil health
is really important to support in our
State especially as we are subject to
droughts and flooding and increasing
Pest and invasive plant
infestations many states have provided
funding to build on their soil Health
legislation and to supplement the gaps
in federal
support often these programs leverage
Federal and private
investment in New Hampshire the base
funding for the conservation districts
comes from our counties and that money
goes to run the administration and
programs for the County Conservation
districts 20% of the revenue from the
Moose plates also go to the conservation
programs the conservation districts
receive no money from UNH extension but
they work with them there is great work
being done in New Hampshire through our
conservation districts with regard to
supporting farmers and their Farm
resilience projects they do a phenomenal
job of leveraging the funds that they
they do receive and they have achieved
great things the conservation districts
have had past philanth philanthropic
support to continue their important and
popular Farm Grant programs but an added
State support component as this bill
requests would accomplish three
important
things first of all state support will
increase the likelihood that current as
well as additional private donors will
continue to support the
programs secondly helping our
agricultural Community improve their
soil will increase yields and production
and thereby increase what the farmers
produce and sell and thereby increase
our state tax
revenues so for the state it is an
important investment in our production
resources direct grants to Farms to
invest in on Farm infrastructure
equipment and Innovative practices
support farm profitability and the
long-term viability of New Hampshire's
agricultural
sector number three helping our
agricultural Community improve their
soil and farming practices will make
their lands more impervious to flooding
droughts and pests and thereby reduce
their need for disaster help from the
state or elsewhere and helping them to
continue to produce food without
interruption the New Hampshire County
Conservation districts their Farm
viability program improves the
resilience of New Hampshire farms in the
face of extreme weather
events there's widespread support for
this work in the agricultural community
and the state established our
conservation districts and this is one
more aspect of the work that they are
doing not only for conservation but for
our agricultural Community as a whole
the mission of the New Hampshire
Conservation District's climate
resilience grant program supports our
New Hampshire Farmers to build soil
resilience throughout the Granite State
farmers utilize the grant funding to
increase resiliency of New Hampshire
farms in a CH a changing climate and
allow for adaptation while meeting the
Farm's conservation goals and needs
extreme weather events frequent and
prolonged droughts and increased pest
pressures are increasing challenges for
for our Farms these grants through the
New Hampshire County Conservation
District seek to support farmers in
meeting those challenges and in closing
I hope that you will agree that $50,000
a year from our general fund for the
next biennium would be a wise investment
in the grant programs that support our
agricultural Community as they struggle
to meet the challenges of dealing with
extreme weather events and increasing
pressures of invasive pests and plants
there there are other testimonies after
me that should demonstrate the successes
of these programs and the need for State
support I would ask that the chair call
uh M Amanda Littleton from the
conservation districts after me and she
can explain more about the the programs
and I would also encourage all the
members of the committee to read some of
the online testimony that has been
submitted because they have some very
important and compelling um things to
say to our committee members I want to
thank you for your time I hope you will
really seriously consider that this
small investment will go a very very
long way to help the vibrancy of our
agricultural Community thank
you uh thank you representative so um
we'll save questions for others is that
what you you may or I I mean I can
answer to the best of my ability but I
think there are folks behind me who are
actually in the trenches uh availing
themselves of the grant funding and also
um who administer the grant funding and
can tell you the successes that they've
been met with all right thank you very
much so we'll just hear from your
co-sponsor representative Bixby and then
you good morning for the record uh
representative Peter Bixby from do New
Hampshire straford District
13 uh and uh I a lot of what I uh have
to say has been covered fairly well by
uh um my colleague but I just want to um
hit a few points to to emphasize them um
just at the outset I want to reemphasize
this is about leveraging PRI more
private donations uh this will P provide
a relatively small portion of the full
um budget for this program but it's an
important to have that small out to get
um other donors to put to uh see this as
a public private
partnership uh I've been a homestead
Gardener for about 25 years now in New
Hampshire and I have watched as the um
weather patterns have changed over the
last uh couple of decades uh we now have
longer exper longer periods of drought
more periods of intense rain
uh it makes it U it's difficult to
adjust to that uh on my scale and where
it's not you know I'm not going to lose
my livelihood if I fail uh I can manage
um but uh if this if you're a farmer you
really need to be able to adjust to
these uh changes in weather and uh one
example is that uh for a very long time
people growing field crops have just fig
figured that there's going to be enough
rain over the summer to uh get the crops
through that's not always the case
anymore um
so uh having the conservation districts
able to provide small grants to the
farmers so they can build their
infrastructure uh to build resilience to
these to the uh different patterns and
weather that we're seeing is really
important uh and uh so that is that is
really the TRS of what this program does
it helps provide more resilience to the
Farms so that they can uh a be more
profitable and B if there is a if there
is adverse weather they don't have the
same level of costs to recover from that
they would that they would before uh I
you were probably here back in 2016 when
we had a bill um that cost the state
more than a million dollars to help
provide help for Dairy Farmers uh who
had been struck very hard by a drought
uh we're hoping that uh with if we can
build propop uh soil resilience that's
not something we're going to be seeing
again where we have to chip in at that
level of money uh a
$50,000 that will help a whole lot of
farms is a lot cheaper than um than than
the recovery money that we could
possibly be asked for if we don't do
that uh so uh just to
um reiterate uh this is a small
investment that we that will have large
paybacks and uh I'd be happy to take
questions but I think that there are
people who are coming up after me who
have more specific examples of how Farms
have been helped in the past we have
some farmers who in fact have had
experience with the program uh and also
more about the det details of how the
Conservation District funding Works uh
from uh Miss Littleton and Mr Hanley yes
thank you representative we we'll do
that um I'll call Amanda Littleton from
District good morning Mr chairman and
rest of the house finance committee
thank you for having me here my name is
Amanda Littleton I'm with the chesher
district is that better great so since
the 1940s the conservation districts
have worked with Farms on the
conservation and responsible use of
natural and agricultural resources so to
further meet that mission in 2022 we
launched this grant program to help
build Farm resilience and it's through
adaptation and mitigation measures the
program was really developed in response
to these extreme weather events that
you've been been hearing about the
frequent and prolonged droughts The
increased press pest pressures and the
livestock heat stress that's caused by
our changing climate what it does is it
provides Farms up to
$10,000 for a grant to implement these
Solutions and challenges that they
identify as the most pressing on their
operations it really does fill a gap
where state and federal dollars fall
short it puts farmers in the driver's
seat they choose what they are applying
for they get to be Innovative and create
the solutions as long as that they are
supported by science and that they are
they are going to be meet the scale of
their Farm business here in New
Hampshire the four categories that Grant
funds are provided in are for soil
Health Water Management on-farm energy
and crop and livestock protection since
since launch in 2022 the districts have
made 95 Grant Awards to Farms investing
over 700
$5,000 these grants have supported farms
in all 10 counties representing 58 towns
which is about 25% of New Hampshire
municipalities additionally 53% of the
awardees are considered historically
underserved the challenge that we face
now is sustaining a program that has
been successful in meeting the needs of
farmers and meeting their demands of
what what they're saying that the the
the climate is providing to them
currently there is not enough funding to
meet the all of the requests that we are
receiving in
applications in the past Grant rounds we
have had to turn down approximately 30%
of
applications and to date as you had
heard earlier this program has been
funded primarily by private donations
and
Foundations but the farmers are
contributing as well they have skin in
the game all of them are contributing
between 25 to 50% of project
costs we're seeking State
support to leverage these private
dollars by the foundations donors and
Farmers to sustain this program bringing
New Hampshire in line with other
northeast states that already support
farms in the similar manner this support
would ensure a Level Playing Field for
New Hampshire Farm
businesses the $50,000 per year that the
for the from the state that we are
requesting to implement this program
would be used for direct grants to
Farmers helping them produce more food
be more profitable and contribute to the
strong agricultural
economy and if successful this would
bring the state as that third partner
with the private donors and the state's
contribution would be 12% of the overall
annual budget for this
program though it's modest it's
absolutely critical it will have an
outsized impact and the public private
partnership would demonstrate a shared
responsibility and encourage private
donors to continue their
support just want to share one quote
from one of the online testimonials I
think this sums it up from one of the
farmers an ounce of prevention is worth
a pound of cure I'm sure you've heard
that well an ounce of this resiliency
planning and implementation is worth
pounds of recovery expenses into the
future for the State of New Hampshire
thank you than you so much for
considering passing this bill we really
appreciate your
consideration thank you very much so uh
question yes representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this this is a topic
that uh is pretty new to me I focus
mostly on healthc care issues um I I'm
I'm I'm curious if the payback on this
program is so high and I'm assuming this
is the assumption that the applicants
are all private citizens looking to make
improvements to private property if the
payback is so
high why aren't they just simply
investing because the payback is so
great what what what is it about this
that makes it a a shared private uh
public
partnership well thank you very much for
the question um I think that agriculture
is a challenging business profit margins
are notoriously slim and it's really
many of them hold a significant debt
load as well um many Farm businesses
find the added Investments for equipment
and infrastructure that are needed are
often put off because of the day-to-day
expenses of their operating costs and
why should it be a shared expense I
think that's a very good question I
think what it comes down to is food
security for the State of New Hampshire
as we move forward um that's one thing I
think the second thing is that many of
these practices are helping to improve
water quality in the state of New
Hampshire as well many of the soil
Health practices are contributing to
less runoff and erosion into our surface
waters we're also helping with the water
management practices for irrigation
those are helping to conserve more water
in many cases because they're moving to
more efficient systems so I think
overall it's a win for the agricultural
community and also for the larger
population of residences in our
state thank you um representative
camroll thank you Mr chair uh I'm just
curious what is the current balance of
the fund so we go on an annual basis for
private funders and so right now we are
we do have an active grant program
underway for 2025 and we hope to provide
$336,000 in Grants to farm businesses
for 2025 and these funds that we are
requesting would go to the 26 and 27
Grant
year thank you other questions
representative Neville uh thank you
chairman I was taking my question Mr
Littleton how many I'm I'm unfamiliar
with the whole farming sector you know
except for the local Farm stands but how
many farms are we talking about in New
Hampshire in total and and what's the
trend in uh say for the last 5 to 10
years I think farms uh you know we see
challenges I I I'll as a proxy I'll use
the number for Dairy Farms as an example
I believe our state of New Hampshire is
down to approximately 60 dairy farms if
you look at the trends going back
hundreds of them in the between 1950s
now so many have gone out of business
and that is a real concern and
especially when you look at our dairy
farms because the land base upon which
they are managing it is the bulk of the
agricultural land and production this is
a trend that can be looked at Beyond
dairy farms though into all of them
because of challenging land prices
having access to land is a real
challenge so the need to support the
Farms that we do have on our
landscape is
critical so again you talk about dairy
farms I'm looking at the whole picture
excuse representative would you like as
followup I'm sorry I would like a quick
yes you may the the question was total
number of farms not just dairy farms uh
but the trend in total Farms I don't
have the numbers of a total number of
farms in the state of New Hampshire but
I can get that for you and I'd be happy
to follow up thank you all right we
still have many more cards and thank so
thank you m thank you for your time I
appreciate it um Ian Hunley from the New
Hampshire State conservation
committee and we'll follow uh by it
County thank you
thank you Mr chairman and committee uh
my name is Ian Hanley I the executive
director of the New Hampshire State
conservation committee uh I want to take
a couple minutes and just provide
overall context for funding of
conservation districts in the state of
New Hampshire as representative Aaron
said in her opening remarks the state
does not provide any overall Operational
Support for our districts um they are
primarily funded at the county level
five of our districts are given a lump
sum from the county that is primarily
used for funding their district manager
position the other five are given a
staff member as a County employee so
their district manager is a County
employee uh beyond that initial sum to
provide a staff member most of our
counties receive or most of our
districts receive little to no
additional support from their County
um other funding sources are primarily
project-based and so as representative
Aaron said they are eligible to apply
for moose plate grants so the SEC runs
the Moose plate grant program um which
districts can apply to again that is
Project based it's tied to a specific
project um they also are eligible for
additional funding through Cooperative
agreement with the natural resource
conservation service and the New
Hampshire Association of conservation
districts again this is performance
Project based
reimbursement other than that districts
are utilizing grant funding program
Revenue uh sales revenue things like
that to provide funding for any of their
programs and so
uh these project-based funding sources
are
not uh able to be applied to the climate
resilience Grant and so as Amanda was
saying the grant funding has been
primarily through private donors and
Foundations and so that's why we bring
this to the state to provide support for
that to help continue this program um in
my testimony I also put have some
numbers in there about what states
surrounding us do at a state level and
also discuss
the financial reporting requirements
that the conservation districts uh do
annually part of my role at the state
conservation committee is making sure
that they're meeting their statutory
obligations to uh for financial
reporting and so I work with them on
that um and I know because we've got a
bunch of farmers and other people that
would like to speak I don't want to go
into too much detail on that but I
provided additional information in my
testimony Mr chairman thank you thank
you very much representative rang thank
you Mr chair um you noted that that you
had written testimony has that been
distributed or was it emailed I don't
have
it
one representative Edward thank thank
you Mr chairman uh again this is uh this
is a new topic to me and and so you're
using the phrasee
climate resilient project and I'm trying
to figure out what that is on the ground
is that a pond is that a retaining wall
is that a tree line is it an umbrella
what what what are we doing to create a
climate resistant Pro or a resilient
project yeah thank you for the question
um as Amanda was saying it is uh this
grant opportunity is open to a variety
of different projects But ultimately
frequently these are addressing either
um increased heavy precipitation events
so heavy rainfall they could be
addressing drought and the Farm's
ability to retain uh water in case of
drought um it affects their they could
apply for projects to help them uh with
energy um you know they could they could
do a whole bunch of things but
ultimately a lot of projects focus on
either the uh dealing with heavy
rainfall events and the flooding that
comes with that or addressing water
retention from droughts that are
becoming more frequent um and we do have
a few Farmers here which are going to
discuss some of their projects in more
detail that they were
doing representative Ms and then we'll
move on thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question hopefully it's a
quick one um you mentioned that the uh
districts do not get do currently do not
get any state funding has that always
been the case or uh did they previously
funding thank you for the question to my
knowledge to the best of my knowledge
they have not if they did this would
have been decades ago that they received
it um when I so I've been in my role for
three and a half years I inherited a few
boxes of old minutes from you know 60s
70s 80s things like that which were
incomplete I tried to go through them as
best as I could but to my knowledge uh
there hasn't been State funding for
districts in um in a while if there was
any at all thank you thank you thank you
very much thank you chairman so we have
um Don and baskam from Sullivan County
there's also another from Sullivan
County Lionel Sho would you maybe like
to come together speak together no okay
well you put down five minutes or six
minutes so we're going to give you a
fraction of that okay well uh good
morning chair and members of the
committee my name is Donna basam and I'm
a resident of Charlestown New Hampshire
Sullivan County and I'm here today to
testify in favor of Bill HB
246 I am a farmer um I'm I'm probably
what you would call a uh in terms of
vegetable production a market scale
Gardener um we also produced my husband
Dean baskam and I raised she for meat we
have about 50 head of sheep we operate a
Sugar Bush of 6,000 Taps and in addition
to the organic vegetable production and
we depend on this
income for our
livelihood uh farming has always been
difficult even in the best of times um
weather conditions in the past decade
however made farming even more
challenging and
risky uh having spent most of my life
and career working outside as a child
growing up in
Maine uh as a soil scientist and as a
soil conservationist in a previous life
also as a sailor on the ocean where you
you're very tied into what's going on
you know in the
weather I can attest that conditions
have become more extreme heat cold rain
events and drought are more and more
unpredictable and you know climate
resiliency means adapting to
unpredictability to the best of your
ability um this grant program has
provided critical access to tools and
equipment that make it possible for
farms in New Hampshire to adapt and
thrive in the face of increasingly
challenging weather conditions this
translates directly into increased
um for Farms of excuse me of food on New
Hampshire farms for consumers in our
state even in the months outside of
normal production Seasons which you
don't really think about but we are now
capable of
producing uh fresh produce well into
December and January even so a lot has
changed in agriculture and that that
makes New Hampshire
farms uh on their way to supplying a
significant amount of our state's food
supply
um and and that's a bonus for Farmers it
increases our
profitability and all of the Farms who
have been able to implement projects
funded by these grants have seen you
know
tremendous uh Improvement in their
farming
operations and I I just want to end with
telling you a story about what um you
know unexpected weather events are like
on May 22nd our farm was preparing for
planting a significant crop of potatoes
and carrots we had land opened up for
seeding uh and out of nowhere came a 4.5
in rain and hail storm that last Ed that
was that was all dropped in a little
over an hour and it caused tremendous
damage and erosion of valuable soil
which is you know a limited resource
that we need to
protect um we could not get those crops
in and it it severely undermined my
growing
season um but now with the help of this
grant this coming year I've been able to
apply for a 100 foot by 16t they're
called caterpillar tunnels and I wish I
will submit a very a five slide um
PowerPoint to for you to all look at to
have a better understanding of what we
mean by climate resiliency and what are
the practices that we use um anyways
that tunnel is going to allow me to
plant even if we have drought or if we
have another flooding season
um it it will give me more resiliency
and more resiliency to produce a crop
for our consumers so I thank you for
your time and attention to this
important bill I'd be happy to answer
any questions the committee may
have questions seeing n thank you very
much Miss basam Mr
Sho and we
will follow with
seeto okay thank you Mr sh uh thank you
hello everyone uh it's a pleasure to be
here today um I'm Lionel Chu I'm the
director of Natural Resources for
Sullivan County and also the district
manager of the Sullivan County
Conservation District I've been doing
this work for uh 12 years now and um I I
I I appreciate the conversation that's
happened so far and I'll try to add some
value to that um just to be clear we're
talking about food we're talking about
the variety of food that we're capable
of producing here in New Hampshire uh
things that range from honey to maple
syrup meat eggs vegetables tree fruits
uh berries dairy grains nuts oil uh
these are all things that we're capable
of of producing and most of us are
enjoying we go out and we uh we hit a
Farm Stand or buy something local and uh
um it's it's part of our quality of life
I would like to say um I really want to
go to the question that representative
Edwards rais because I think it's
critical and Central to the discussion
and the question was if the payback is
high why are public dollars needed and
I'd like to share a little something
with
you according to the 2022 USDA census of
Agriculture 80%
of commercial New Hampshire
Farms grossed under
$25,000 per
year
92% of New Hampshire Farms grossed under
$100,000 per
year and this is consistent with the
Farms of my county of Sullivan County
76% of farms are grossing less than
$25,000 and 90% are grossing less than
$100,000
so this is gross and not net in good
years most Farms are averaging a net
profit of about
10% so if a farm is grossing less than
$100,000 which would be 90% of all the
farms in the
state then they're netting less than
$10,000 and that
$10,000 has to cover family living
income tax principal on land non-
depreciable
expenses so for for 80% of New Hampshire
Farms grossing under
$25,000 the average yearly profit is
$2500 so not surprisingly every a census
since
2007 has consistently shown that between
68 and 72% of New Hampshire Farms have
negative cash net cash from
operations negative net cash from
operations which means that there is no
depreciation taken for tractors for
buildings for equipment Etc so we're
talking about an agricultural system
that is really Hanging On by a
thread and these funds the other
question that I wanted to respond to is
U conservation districts have never
received uh State funding since they
started in the' 40s um and and this is
not uh a change of that policy because
this is strictly pass through funding so
we're talking about bringing
$5,000 per District strictly for the
purpose of this Grant and nothing else
it it will never see the these dollars
we'll we'll simply incorporate it in our
grant round for the climate resiliency
Grant and we'll have an extra $5,000 per
district for two years to to pair up
with the 30 to $40,000 of private money
that we'll have um but we'll be able to
go back to the private funders and say
Yes New Hampshire does value this and
they were willing to to put a little
something in for it so and that will
make all the difference because our
private funders are at the point where
you know they're saying yeah we're into
it we want to do this but does the state
care and and so that's why we're here
today so um I would really enjoy any
additional question otherwise that's all
I've got today representative
please thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question do you have
any cost figures about the what it costs
the farmers when we have a severe
weather event and and who pays for that
cost yeah excellent um you know it's a
mess it's it's really it's tough the uh
natural resources conservation service
is the only Federal agency that uh
provides assistance to farms uh in New
Hampshire and um they track all of that
i' I'd be happy to develop that for you
I don't have the statistics but I can
tell you just sort of conceptually that
we're talking about things that happen
um all of a sudden someone's wiped out
they've they've lost everything or
they've lost a lot of what they had
that's all their profit it's also a
whole lot of people depending on that
food their supply chain a ripple effects
as you might imagine and so that is
being tracked we have Federal disaster
declarations which are critical um but a
lot of times things are happening that
don't quite rise to that level they're
still wiping people out um and so uh
there are folks that are tracking that
and if if you would like more
information I can get that for
you all right one follow as a followup I
would also like to see uh if you have
any figures or statistics about the
implementation of a of of a
weather um resiliency climate resiliency
programs have on Farmers if there is a
reduction of their cost cost to they you
know yes well we we're doing that now so
we're we're tracking our metrics uh from
the time that we started our pilot three
years ago um we require all of the grant
recipients to First identify for us uh
how this is going to benefit them and
then document uh the the improvements
that have happened and so um very fast I
can just tell you we've had projects
that included a solar track or array uh
silvo pasture and rotational grazing uh
we put in a water well uh for a farm
that uh the field went completely dry it
had been fine for over 150 years that
that that family had been farming
continuously on the land um and so yes
we are tracking those things everything
has to make sense we have such limited
resources that we have to be careful
about who we give this money to and make
sure that we're really making a
difference
here thank you thank you very much Mr sh
we have Mr
sampo yes and followed by the Robinsons
from
Pittsburgh good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Steven scapo I am the President of the
New Hampshire Association of
conservation
districts NH J CD is is the acronym that
we use so that's further
down I am here to testify and support in
the inclusion of the $50,000 in the
state budget to fund the climate
resiliency Grant nhad supports all 10
conservation districts across the state
of New Hampshire working collaboratively
to support the state's Agricultural and
natural resource
communities one of the goals of the
conservation districts is to help the
small new and underserved Farmers
survive and prosper in the face of the
current
challenges over the past few years the
climate resiliency grant program has
provided critical support to these
Farmers enabling them to implement
Innovative and sustainable practices
that improve farm profitability and
operational efficiency to date the
program has awarded more than $700,000
in Grants with an additional
$330,000 allocated for this year these
grants capped $10,000 per AE have proven
instrumental in supporting projects that
enhanced productivity and reduced
operational costs for many
farms however up to this point all the
funding for the program has come
primarily from private sources while we
deeply appreciate the generosity and
commitment of our private Partners it is
clear that long-term sustainability of
this program requires a public private
partnership by allocating $50,000 in
state funding which is just 12% of the
program's annual budget New Hampshire
would signal its commitment to
supporting the agricultural community in
ensuring the program's future this
modest investment would have an outside
impact it would enable us to extend the
reach of the program supporting more
farmers in ensuring the benefits of
these grants such as improved
operational efficiency Inc inre
profitability and enhance Farm
sustainability all felt across our
communities furthermore by leveraging
the funding State funding
alongside private contributions we can
create a model of shared responsibility
in Partnership that underscores the
importance of this work New Hampshire's
farmers are the backbone of our rural
economy and they face increasing
pressures to remain competitive and
viable by supporting this funding by
supporting this funding you are not only
investing in this success but also in
the economic health and resilience of
our state's
agricultural sector I urge you to
include this $50,000 in the state budget
for climate resiliency grants thank you
for your time and
consideration thank you very much so um
next we have um Rebecca and Keith
berri uh good morning chair and members
of the committee my name is Rebecca
Robinson and I'm here to represent my
family farm we live in northern Coos
County we operate a small beef Farm on
250 Acres raising the fourth generation
we are both working we are one of two
working Farms in the town of Pittsburgh
both my husband and I work full-time
jobs to be able to fund the farm and
enhance better
practices and to improve our re
resilience from Farms from storms sorry
I'm nervous our family has received this
Grant and with the funds we have
improved our manure pit to collect storm
water and to protect our hay feed from
the rain and snow snow which is to which
is to keep our waterways clean if we
hadn't received the funds the projects
would not have been able to get done
when we receive the grant funds we have
focused our funds to be spent in our
local town and state businesses I hope
that you increase the funds for this
grant so more Farmers have the same
opportunity that we have been able
practices thank you very much Miss
Robinson is Keith is this your husband
together good morning Keith Robinson
from Pittsburgh New Hampshire I'm one of
the co-chairs for the supervisor of the
Coos Conservation District and the
climate resilience Grant is a great way
to help Advance economic opportunities
for the farmers and producers the
current funding allows us in Kos County
to select three to five different Grant
applicants uh each year depending on
their funding requests and if more money
were appropriate we might able to uh
fund more farms and
producers um with the priz of inflation
and changing of weather patterns
influenced by climate change farmers and
producers are facing increasing
challenges in securing funding for
virtual Improvement projects essentially
for our ecosystem Kos county has awarded
grants to a variety projects including
including storm water collection systems
enhancing hay field quality and
retrofitting equipment for no till use
practices and installing energy
efficient solar panels these grants
demonstrate our commitment as a board to
encourage more Farms to producers to
apply so they can have the opportunity
to thrive and succeed in their
operation thank you thank you Mr
Robinson so uh Mr bururi
Rickie good morning um my name is Tom
bodri I live in
Walpole I had a dairy farm for 40 years
I currently raise grass-fed bees and I'm
also a crop consultant I work in New
Hampshire Vermont little bit in
massachusett
um oh and I am an associate supervisor
with the Cheshire County Conservation
District I'll be brief 20 years ago 6%
of New Hampshire's landbase was in
agriculture now I expect that's less
than
5% um for various
reasons it's very important to have a
vibrant profitable resilient egg sector
producing high quality food for local
consumption the Cent resilient grants
have helped numerous Producers Dairy
beef poultry fruits vegetables Lio went
on with a bunch of them
um in the work that I
do and I get around various States we
always hear a lot about the New
Hampshire
Advantage okay having to do with
businesses and quality of life I can
tell you for a fact that New Hampshire
EG agriculture is at a disadvantage when
we look at neighboring
states
um really not much support state support
or from the Department of a as
well I am a strong supporter of
Agriculture that's how I've made my
living for over 50
years I asked this committee to be
supportive of this house bill to provide
50,000 to help Leverage the funding that
has been used for for three years and
the grant is open this year thank you
very much for coming all right um Mr
Rickie yes and uh last one would be
good morning chair and members of the
committee my name is Jack rxy I am a
resident of Fitz William and I'm here
today to testify in support of House
Bill
246 I own and operate Dog Days Farm in
Fitz William uh we distribute our
produce through weekly weekly pickups on
the farm uh which is attended by over
200 families each week through the
summer we sell wholesale to the local
co-ops and small grocery stores we also
operate three farmers markets uh one of
which were there today this morning uh
one of my employees is there at the
chesher chesher Medical Center Hospital
in Kean um I'm also a recipient of this
grant aside from that I do not have an
affiliation with the Conservation
District despite being support other
than being supported by them um through
both services and Grant programs uh we
received a grant to purchase an
agricultural flame weeder in 2023 and
I'll be applying for the grant this year
to en enhance some of our green houses
in
2025 these pieces of equipment allow us
to farm efficiently uh and profitably uh
and support our business which this is a
fledgling business for me I've worked at
the farm for nine years uh this I'm
going into my third year of owning the
farm I'm not sure if any of y'all are
small business owners but uh if anybody
is you can attest to the fact that there
are high startup costs uh coupled with
debt that we take on to purchase the
farm uh and to operate the farm that
makes it difficult to purchase pieces of
equipment uh agricultural equipment is
notoriously high cost um and without
this grant we would not be able to
purchase some of the vital pieces of
equipment that we use to farm profitably
to keep our pay our employees a fair
wage and to protect our soil which is
the most important part of our farm uh
thank you for having me here today and I
am open to any questions thank you Mr
rxy representative Ms thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming in um when
you purchased the equipment that you
were able to buy with this grant um did
you buy that from local
businesses we that piece of equip is a
that is a specialized piece of equipment
uh I believe we get it out of Illinois
uh a lot of farm equipment is produced
in the Midwest because New England is
not considered typically or is not a hub
for uh larger farm equipment uh in the
United States so a lot of those
producers are out in the midwest quick
quick
followup um did you buy it directly from
Illinois or through a dealer in New
Hampshire uh it was through a dealer out
of Virginia okay however the grant that
we will be applying for in 2025 uh we
will be buying all of that equipment
from uh a New Hampshire business Rim all
green houses there are lots of
businesses in New Hampshire that produce
equipment just this specialized piece of
equipment is not produced in New
Hampshire great thank you thank you very
much for coming so Mr Trimble is our
last
one morning Mr chairman and committee
members uh my name is David Trumble I'm
from the aware I own and operate Good
Earth Farm I've been a farmer for over
40 years and I've run my own business
for 39 years uh it's a family farm we
hire part-time seasonal help and sell
mostly directly to the consumers
although some wholesale um I'll try and
get to some of the key points first is
linking this to climate
resilience I looked at the website of
this program we have not filed for one
of these grants although I am looking at
doing it for this year uh the the
programs are amazing if you can scroll
down the map and just hit on each of the
stars and see what they've done and I've
been around farming New Hampshire so I
know a lot of the people and these are
really really good farmers and they I'm
not here today because they're home
working on their Farms but what the
things they've done have been very
productive so I just want to talk about
one example which is soil Health if you
can reduce the tillage of your soil then
you can protect your soil health so some
of the equipment is no till Planters
perfecta field cultivators silage tarps
things like that that you can use these
grants for if you reduce the tillage on
your soil you're not breaking down
organic matter why does that matter the
general rule thumb is every 1% of
organic matter gives you about a week of
protection against drought so if you're
plowing up that field and like the old
days just harrowing it and harrowing it
the organic matter is going to drop
there goes your drought resistance
another thing thing as exposed Fields
being able to get in and out quickly uh
using the silage tarps you can get into
your cover crop quickly or you can get
into your cash crop quickly why is that
important because single weather events
generally account for one single weather
event a third of soil erosion in the
United States no I'm not saying one
weather event in the whole country but I
guess saying on a farm it's usually just
one event causes tremendous damage if
you can get more quickly into where you
need to go plant your crop then you have
roots in the ground you don't have the
effects of the erosion so these expenses
are protecting the soil and that goes to
the question of why is this a public
partnership the farmer has a duty to
leave the farm better than when they
started there but it's not just for your
own Farm sake you are managing that land
for the future of our society so we as
Farmers have a duty to everybody to
protect the soil to protect the land and
this grant here is saying hey we're as a
Society going to help you protect the
land and the speaker just said we're
down we lost the whole percent of
agricultural land from 6 to 5% the best
protection for New Hampshire's open land
is a successful working farm if the land
is not being used productively it's
eventually going to go to Shrub or it's
going to be developed into something
else if you want to keep New Hampshire
with open land you want to have
successful working Farms there also
there's the economic aspect of it
there's 4,000 is farms in New Hampshire
that uh generate $120 million a year in
Wages that's direct Farm wages when you
figure in the multiplier effects you
know every dollar that goes into a farm
is spent you get a 3 to1 rough
multiplier the total economic output of
New Hampshire Farms is over $500 million
a year and that's from a 2019 Department
of Agriculture report called the
economic impact of agriculture in New
Hampshire and it's obvious ly a little
bit probably about the same now we lost
a little land but inflation's gone up so
you're talking about a half a billion
dollars it's huge so Farms are important
for the future of our soil they're
important for us growing food they're
also important to our e our economy so
um I would urge this you to please join
in with the other states around us that
are trying to say farming is an
important sector of our economy we have
a lot of programs in the state
government that help a lot of different
sectors helping the Farms is also
valuable thank you thank you very much
Mr trumo so we had also a uh blue sheet
with 12 names on it nine of which you've
heard from so there are three new ones
all in favor so I'm going to close the
public hearing for House Bill 246 I want
to thank all the people who drove such a
long way to be here with us and I will
recognize the prime sponsor for House
Bill 519 our own uh representative
W go
ahead thank
you thank you representative m and
members of the U committee I'm Mary Jane
walner I'm supposed to be sitting up
there um and I'm glad to be here today
sitting here to uh bring this bill forth
uh the purpose of House Bill 519 is to
provide an appropriation designated to
Waypoint and New Hampshire nonprofit
social service agency for the purpose of
providing a Youth Shelter in Manchester
the Waypoint Manchester shelter is the
only emergency shelter in New Hampshire
for young adults aged 18 to 24 who are
experiencing homelessness the shelter
opened in October of
2022 and was operated at has operated at
capacity with its 14 beds being filled
every night for the past two
years in 2023 the shelter sered 90
served 98 young adults and in 2024 it
served 79 young young people every night
that the shelter has been open there
were young people who were turned away
because the shelter was at
capacity in addition to the shelter
Waypoint runs a dropin center which
supports 163 youth last year the shelter
and the dropin Center provide more than
temporary place to stay they offer case
management connection to critical
resources and Pathways to stability
working with these young youth early in
their adult life is essential not only
for reducing chronic homelessness but
also for saving public funds in the long
run the age range of 18 to 24 is a
critical time for social emotional and
financial development as youth become
independent experiences during this time
of life impact the trajectory of young
people well into their adult lives
Waypoint needs $500,000 a year to
continue to operate this critical
program for New Hampshire home homeless
youth the director of the shelter and
the executive director of wayo are both
here and we'll be able to talk with you
more about the financial situation of
the
shelter and I am open to questions thank
you representative
questions representative Edwards
um I I have U two general policy
questions um that you may be able to
answer you may not um um first is um I
was surprised that this came directly to
finance committee without going through
a policy committee first do do you
happen to have any idea how what was
behind the decision to stand straight to
finance instead of going through a
policy committee no I have no no
information about that thing thank you
thank you
followup um I am assuming and and you
could clarify my assumption that there
are other um Youth and Young Adult
shelters in New Hampshire uh and that
there there's a program managed by
DHHS why wouldn't this be part of the
standard budget process instead of a
one-off funding request what what what
makes this a one-off funding request
my understanding is that the Waypoint
shelter for youth is the only Youth
Shelter in the state and I think that
when um the executive director from
Waypoint comes up I think you can
explore with him a little bit more about
the funding and uh why the funding's
needed and what the relationship is with
the Department of Health and Human
Services around it I think the
department might also be here today um
and be able to talk a little bit more
thoroughly about the financing thank you
for taking my questions thank you Mr
shair all right any other questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative walner we also have
nashwa thank you very much for letting
me speak today um I just wanted to give
a little bit of um background and
perspective on youth homelessness here
in in uh New Hampshire I don't know
everything that's happening with youth
homelessness across the state um but I
do know kind of what's happening in
nashaa um there was another youth
homeless program um in NASA that closed
its do in April of last year um it was
not associated with DHHS it was not
funded by the state in any way it was a
private uh charitable organization um
however uh their funding dried up they
had some board member problems and they
closed on April 12 and gave this the um
kids who were there two weeks to find
alternate living arrangements um my
understanding is most of those kids were
not able to find alternative living
arrangements I have no idea where they
are now a few of them went up to
Manchester um most of them are just
floating in the wind um the way that
DHHS deals with homeless youth is they
are only responsible for kids who have
aged out of foster care um or resid
itial placement um and that is a
voluntary program um and kids have the
right to say no and many do many don't
want to stay in foster care or stay in a
group home um and follow whatever rules
there are and curfews uh once they turn
18 um those kids if they say no to that
program there is no other alternative
for them except for this Waypoint Youth
Shelter um we do have other homeless
shelters in the state OB viously uh New
Hampshire uh naswa has the uh NASA soup
kitchen and shelter uh which has 75 beds
um those beds are all full every night
um this year um we also have in in naswa
a warming station which you can't sleep
there it's like tables in the cafeteria
at the Old El Street School building um
and that averages about 22 people a
night um we do know that in naswa 211
had over a 100 calls last year from you
aged 18 to 24 who are unable to find a
place to sleep for the night um and
those kids were not placed anywhere
because there's no longer a you shelter
in NWA so um that's just the data that I
have and hopefully it helps you when
you're making the decision on uh what
the state can do to help this vulnerable
group thank you representative
representative Edwards has a question uh
thank you Mr chair um do you happen to
know um if there is a a depart
department or an element of DHHS that's
uh provide some sort of Regulation or
oversight to this particular shelter uh
so there's a couple of different ones um
it's managed through the normal cpsws in
the office um so usually it's the
permanency worker um so they have
something called hope the housing and
opportunities to personally Excel
program um but again participants have
to follow a voluntary placement
agreement um and they can continue to
have an open case um those kids
typically stay in a foster home um
because they are only a couple of
independent living homes like the
Nashville Children's Home only has I
forget how many beds but it's less than
five um and then there's the after care
services um and those are both through
DCF yep all right I don't see any other
hands thank you very much now we have um
bigh El
Alvarez too yes that would be me go go
come on up if I may ask Mandy lanter
who's the program director he might make
sense to understand the shelter and I
can talk after of the finances that's
okay chairman yes that's fine yes Mandy
Lancaster both of you are from Waypoint
can Mr chairman yes
also put a card yes may I sit with
okay good morning chairman Maguire and
the finance committee I guess it's noon
so maybe that's not fully appropriate um
this is my first time testifying or
providing
testimony and I am um humbly um coming
here this morning to support h B 519 so
again my name is Mandy Lancaster I am a
social worker by trade I have worked in
Social Services for 20 years now 18 of
those years have been in New Hampshire I
do some adjunct work at the State
University um and I've worked at
Waypoint for over 10 years now and so
Waypoint is one of New Hampshire's
largest and oldest
nonprofits and we provide support
Supportive Services throughout the state
of New Hampshire to include supporting
Youth and Young adults experiencing
homelessness as well as young people in
foster care that need therapeutic
supports core ordered and voluntary
community-based and home supports and
services and we also support folks in
their homes that um require our aged um
neighbors and um friends too and so the
state of homelessness in New Hampshire
the New Hampshire coalition to end
homelessness indicated in their 2024
report that
52.1% there was a an increase of Youth
homelessness in the state by
52.1% and um that also means that New
Hampshire experienced the largest
increase of Youth and Young Adult
homelessness in the country and We
Believe at Waypoint that early
intervention through programs like ours
are essential for reducing chronic
homelessness which ultimately saves
public funds in the long run and a so a
core Mission and objective of our
programs um through the homeless Youth
and Young Adult department is to
interrupt that experience of chronic
homelessness which I think we could
probably all agree um strains um people
and communities throughout our
state last year the National Conference
of state legislators found that in the
US approximately 1 in 10 young adults
between the ages of 18 to 25 experien
homelessness and 1 and 30 between the
ages of 13 and
17 and in New Hampshire again
25% of the homeless population are those
at or under 25 years of age and one in
four reside in the city of
Manchester so we believe that shelter is
a part of the
solution um our demographic that we
provide services to at 298 Handover
Street are 18 to 24 year olds that are
fleeing domestic violence they're aging
out of foster care they're leaving
unsafe housing situations
they're experiencing um parental
incarceration parental death we see
often mental health issues not only for
the young person but what they're
experiencing in their family
systems and so I would say those are the
biggest trends of young people that we
see in our
programs we are the only emergency
shelter for young people in New
Hampshire and so I appreciate that this
um um this request is Manchester based
we often see young people navigate
between Rochester Manchester and nashaa
those are the three communities that
young people um seem to have most
familiarity with and when young people
are um disrupted and have no place um to
call home or no one to turn to they look
to what is familiar and something I'm
particularly proud of from a program
perspective is that this shelter is more
than a bed so this isn't about providing
a cot and a meal for young people we the
the shelter is attached to an engagement
Center and where it's a hub and it's a
hub and a pathway towards other
Supportive Services that include
Transitional Living programs
Transitional Living programs for
parenting and Pregnant young people we
have rapid rehousing programs we have
youth navigation and we even have three
rent controlled units on the top floor
of 298 Handover
Street um additionally and this really
speaks to the program part um moving
beyond this notion that shelter is a bed
I we have a myriad of life skills groups
we have a professional um development
manager who works with young people to
promote access to work vocation even
College um we're also we have other um
Folks collocate at the center to have
mental health needs met um and we also
provide parenting support and resources
by way of Our Family Resource Center and
so all of this is put in place towards
longer term
Solutions since the shelter opened it
has operated at capacity and has served
over
340 youths through the dropin center and
177 youth at our emergency shelter on
average each night we turn away um
upwards of 20 young people and we safety
plan with them and we call Community
Partners some young people stay in their
vehicles um and and so this really I
think think illustrates the need for
emergency Sheltering for young people
throughout our
state so I think as Illustrated the
shelter provides an essential benefit to
the individuals it supports or it it
serves but it also supports the
Manchester Community um again the hope
and the objective is to decrease chronic
homelessness there is research that
indicates that when a young person
enters into an adult homeless service
system and um I have deep respect for
those that do that work that they are at
an exponential increased risk of
experiencing chronic homelessness just
by way of having close proximity to
people that are already experiencing
chronic
homelessness so too the shelter helps um
provide um or addresses the worker
shortages by improving Workforce
participation which is evidenced um by
way of our work with the professional
development and growth manager and it
helps address the um business
community's needs and reasonably their
concerns around um literal homelessness
and the impact that it has on business
because we provide um a space and an
opportunity to engage young people so
they're not um interfering with business
operations
um by providing shelter and Supportive
Services we decrease the Reliance on
emergency service calls law enforcement
um um with interaction with the criminal
justice system which reduces public
spending in those
Arenas so I believe that this is a
meaningful opportunity for legislators
to make an impact on the Manchester
Community but also throughout the state
by supporting Youth and Young adults
that access the shelter and in the
engagement Center um so that we can
continue to Elevate New Hampshire's
youth out of
homelessness I thank you for your
consideration I do ask humbly that you
vote Yes on HB 519 and I would be happy
to answer any
questions questions yes representative
string of
yeah thank you very much for coming in
and and offering the great service you
do to the community um can you comment
uh you know since you're asking for
specific or the bill asks for specific
appropriation what the budget is for
your facility I assume you're a
nonprofit and what your other sources of
revenue are yes I I can speak to that
generally and um executive director
borha Alvarez de Toledo can certainly
speak to it with more definitiveness
um in the homeless Youth and Young Adult
Department we rely heavily on federal
pass through dollars from the Family
Youth Services Bureau which is embedded
within the larger DHHS landscape we are
also a recipient of Hud funding and have
a number of programs that
um were supported through HUD uh a bulk
of our dollars comes from charitable
giving and our aggressive
fundraising efforts annually and so it
really is a public private
partnership and with all of the income
and the revenue coming in we still have
a shortfall to operate the shelter there
are no clear um avenues for supporting a
shelter such as ours adult shelter beds
are um um by bed night and we operate a
a program that's beyond beds so that we
can help young people um move so that
homelessness for young people is brief
and non reoccurring and to again meet
that objective of reducing chronic
homelessness does that
help uh it it does um uh you know I do
have question follow this yes is this
all right thank you sir um just just you
know o overall how much money flows
through the organization if somebody
else was better to answer that that's
okay too that would definitely be the Ed
we're a large nonprofit and there are
multiple departments in the agency so I
would feel better for him to defer to
borha thank
you representative Daniels thank you is
your annual report online it is online
yesk representative priest and followed
by representative run thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question and thank you for the
outstanding service that you do for the
city of Manchester and for the State of
New Hampshire thank you I am a resident
and I see what you are doing do you have
any figures that shows how you have
reduced The
Chronic homelessness through your
programs to through the youths that
enter your shelter and the engagement
facility
how many of those are now productive
citizens of New Hampshire at this point
I can't give you a number I can speak
anecdotally and I would be happy to loop
back around and thank you for the
question and so um there are young
people that enter into college we had at
least five this year that we helped set
them up in their dorm rooms we have 20
rapid rehousing beds throughout the
state we have three Beach Street units
and we also have um upwards of 20
Transitional Living Spaces and five nine
units for transitional living for
pregnant and parenting and we also work
closely with the division um DHHS to
connect young people to FYI vouchers and
those are vouchers for young people
exiting foster care um there's a
bottleneck
and so we the engagement Center and the
shelter and the programming is vitally
important because we connect young
people to those programs and other
programs throughout the state that have
youth specific Housing Programs
um I hope that helps
okay representative run thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
and thank you for all the great work you
do my question is with this 500,000 for
each of the two years the B Anum how
much of that would be going to uh a
fixed cost outlay for instance beds
things like that rather than um ongoing
something like I guess what I'm trying
to get at is uh in two years would you
find you would need at least this amount
of money to maintain
operations or to augment your operations
yeah um it would certainly the two Fe
would be vital in augmenting operations
and there is a fear that if we don't
identify ongoing support that we would
look at closure much like our friends in
nashaa which I think would be quite
devastating for young people in our
state um and it would at least give us
two years to continue to do some
additional sustainability planning and I
believe that borha could um contribute
to that question question as
well all right one problem okay thank
you and then uh you mentioned about the
pregnancy um young parenting support
that you give to these youth how many of
the um youth that or the young adults
that come in are have children that go
that come with them or babies many many
we have a play pen in the Drop in Center
um in the shelter young people can stay
and we have had young people stay and
until they delivered their children and
they didn't have anyone to go with them
and were quite literally in the delivery
room um with some young people and um we
because we have the case management
staff and the life skills groups and the
parenting groups we um work with those
young people to plan prior proper
planning so one specific youth that I'm
thinking of was able to transition into
to her own apartment from the hospital
and another into our Transitional Living
Program for pregnant and parenting young
people okay we certainly are seeing an
increase in um pregnancy and young
babies in the center thank you
yes representative Edwards uh yeah thank
you Mr chair um so you sound like your
mission is extremely similar similar to
The Liberty house I don't know if you
know the Liberty house model but I was
on the board of directors for them for
three years and so I I really admire and
respect and want to uh I'm biased to
wanting to support your program because
it sounds like it's vital but um so this
this bill will end up going to division
three so there's some time to think
about this but what I'm what I'm really
curious about and interested in on your
behalf is is that um
you all are put into a sustainable
framework right now it feels like you're
a little autonomous like very autonomous
given that you're coming to us on a
one-time shot for the first round of
funding so so I'd like to see what your
proposal is for getting into a
sustainable model Liberty house went to
Catholic Charities other organizations
become affiliated with DHHS funding
systems and and and so so if you would
help me understand um that if if we were
to put money into you that it's
sustainable and that you have a a
framework for the future and and that's
a lot for today but we you you have time
to think about that yeah that is a big
and good question and thank you for that
um what I do know is that um many of our
neighboring states throughout New
England I believe all of them have
some um have legislation on the books
some form of runaway and homeless youth
act in which their
DHHS um systems provide ongoing support
to run to to homeless Youth and Young
adults
um as an important prevention strategy
to again
address chronic homelessness later
um I don't know that we're there yet and
I think that borha can speak to some of
this as well but without a doubt it
would seem as though there will need to
be a private
partner um a um a
partnership you know in my perfect world
um um moving forward and to to recognize
that you know up to 40% of young people
experiencing chronic homelessness have
been involved in child welfare so um so
response does does your colleague wish
to
speak thank you Emily Lawrence the
advocacy director with Waypoint and I'm
going to leave this right now to the
expert um I will also join um our CEO
borha in case there are any questions
that I can answer but she's done a great
job all right thank you very much we
will now hear from okay thank you uh yes
Mr uh
D if I'm pronouncing it correctly yes
good um Mr chairman uh members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
for the record my name because it's a
hard one so I I recognize is borha
alvare too and I have the privilege of
serving as CEO of Waypoint and have for
the last 11 years um I'm going to try to
sort of give a context about sort of
financially how we have sustained um the
shelter but also what we're facing going
forward um about five years ago when we
had an internal meeting with Senior
Management to really determine whether
or not we were providing the services
that the youth experience um
experiencing homelessness needed the
number one question is we we don't have
an emergency shelter that's a crucial
piece of a Continuum of Care for any
system and actually New Hampshire was
the only New England State without a
specified um emergency shelter for youth
um we we knew we couldn't come to the
state and say would you fund this um
trust me we had tried um it was a
complicated thing um so we embarked in a
capital campaign and raised $2.5 million
to actually build a number of things but
$1.7 million were to build the shelter
um that Mandy Lancaster has told you
about it's the building on 298 um
Hanover Street which used to be the New
Hampshire Works site in um and actually
was owned by the state so actually we
bought that from the state I um
innocently went to governor sununu and
asked if he could give me the the
building and he says you have to
convince 400 legislators I'm like okay
I'll figure it out so um in anyway I um
we bought and renovated the building um
and it's been operating as a shelter um
as as Mandy has shared with you
basically on the first week uh the
shelter was full all the beds were full
but we did not have operational money we
knew we needed two staff from 700 p.m.
to 7:00 a.m. every single night 3 65 and
a supervisor um and so I actually went
to um meet with governor sununu and said
this is the predicament we've actually
built this we need fundings to operate
this shelter um he was incredibly
supportive and actually very grateful
that we had actually undertaken this
funding and this building and he knew
the agency well because actually
Governor sonono has participated three
years in our major fundraiser which is
the sleepout where the business
community um and leaders um actually
sleep in the cold in March to raise
awareness and funds and last year we
raised
$400,000 um so he knew our programs well
and said I'm going to I'm going to
support uh with $500,000 a year this
this was in the last budget cycle I
received notification from his office
that um he had actually increased the
line for homeless and shelter Services I
believe it went up uh three times to
about $10 million what he didn't do
though is um say that half um half a
million of those 500,000 would be um ear
marked if you want or dedicated to
Waypoint so when it came to the
Department of Health and Human Services
they released a request for proposal and
it was really a funding um sort of a
more traditional shelter which is based
on volume so I think the rate was
$18.50 per bed uh per night uh for us
with 14 beds that might work for a
shelter that has 150 but as Mandy has
explained this is way more than a bed we
have intensive case management we follow
um the youth uh and actually transition
then to A Drop in Center so it was going
to be about $92,000 and we knew by then
that the operations was about $600,000
to fund the shelter
um we were a little desperate because we
had open the shelter and in three months
we were facing closing it so I actually
went and met with uh commissioner Weaver
and Deputy Commissioner hen and said
we believe um Governor sununu really
intended to put this money and to
support the shelter um the way it's it's
actually being rolled out is not going
to help us um I knew there were meetings
between the department and governor
sununu and um the commissioner came and
actually visited the the the center uh
with Deputy Commissioner hen and they
realized that this is not funding a bet
this is funding a whole intervention for
youth um they were able to secure half a
million dollars $500,000 for 18 months
which was not enough to fund the full
shelter but we committed to keep the
doors open and we really committed also
to fund raise for the difference um to
make sure that we had the shelter
operating at capacity over night um it
also gave us 18 months and the idea was
that the state was going to figure out
how to put in uh this bium budget um you
know funding for the shelter because
they recognize that it is the only
shelter for youth in New Hampshire and
it's actually a service that is
needed um unfortunately um it has not
made it to effic to the efficiency
budget um it is um listed as a
priority we are very aware of the fiscal
climate and position that the state is
and are very very worried that it's not
going to make it into the budget and
what it will mean is July 1st we have no
funding uh at all for um the shelter and
we will be forced to put potentially
close it now the whole division of um um
runaway and homeless youth services that
um was described uh by my colleague
Mandy is about $4 and5 million dollar in
services and as she um alluded to um we
receive most of the funding uh from
federal funds um the only funding that
we have received from the state is that
bridge money half a million dollars for
the 18 months and we have to raise every
single year to support These funds
because they have match we the these
Federal contracts have match we have to
raise $1.2
million and we have been committed to
doing this through various ways we have
had support from foundations actually
one of the funding for the shelter was
uh through um Senator Shaheen um you
know congressionally directed support um
and of through Hut through the city of
Manchester so um adding another half a
million dollars are actually six 00,000
to um our portfolio having to raise
money is is not something that we can do
um and we feel that two and a half years
the the the um shelter has really worked
and helped many many youth um and we
just want to turn to the state to say we
we need your help in supporting this we
have actually carried this uh through
fundraising and many of the services and
that is certainly the expectation um
that we have of the community Mee um I I
just want to say that there's um um
mayor um Jay R from Manchester has
actually submitted a letter of support I
wasn't sure if he had emailed the letter
to you or I was supposed to print it so
I don't have it but I will get to all of
you uh the mayor has actually visited
the shelter and has been extremely
supportive of the services understanding
that we are the only provider that does
this emergency shelter in Manchester
which is absolutely
needed um
so I'll stop here because there were a
lot of questions that were sort of like
you know punted to me so I'm sure
there's uh questions representative
Edwards very question uh thank you very
much I I'm I'm taking puzzle pieces here
and I'm I'm this is what I think I've
put together from your testimony and
others and Miss Fox maybe maybe you can
clarify this for us but it sounds to me
like uh Waypoint has visibility within
the Department of Health and Human
Services that the managers of uh the
appropriate family and youth services
programs are are aware of of you uh are
predisposed to wanting to work with you
and to help you uh but in this budget
process they couldn't find room in in
their their efficiency budget and so the
from their perspective they put Waypoint
into a a priority need category so so
when the the governor's budget comes to
us we're going to be seeing a a
prioritized need for for Waypoint and
and maybe that's too much government
bureaucracy for you but I that is my
understanding as well this is how it's
going but at the same time yeah I am
hearing that um because of the
situations are now it's not clear that
many of that
prioritized so follow up so so so I
think the conclusion to that is that
this bill is a supplemental Bill to
augment the activities of what DHHS is
doing through the budget process it's
not that you were forgotten or
overlooked it's just that uh people are
so concerned about your program that
they've provided us with the
supplemental Bill to consider that is
really a good summary uh we are
continuing to work with the budget
process and certainly our hope is the
that the new governor puts it in but we
also want some assurances and actually
to share with the committee that
otherwise we will not have a shelter and
cannot operate the shelter outstanding
testimony thank you sir and and thank
you for what you're doing to for the
kids thank you represent
okay all right so we have um thank you
very much for coming we have four more
speakers um we'll start with Mr Barry
um so I have a hard stop at 1:00 we are
40 minutes over already so I would ask
people people to be brief and this will
three how's
that my name is Elliot Barry I'm a
retired private citizen enjoying
retirement but enjoying being here as
well uh but I know it's lunchtime and
I'll move I'll move along quickly for 47
years I was an attorney at New Hampshire
legal assistance uh the last decade or
so decade or so I was a director of
housing Justice
uh I have and again especially over the
last decade SE had countless young
clients who had such an array of
problems that are uh addressed in one
way or another uh by the shelter uh I
had clients who couldn't obtain housing
because of certain deficits and problems
in their past uh slews of eviction cases
where they're getting evicted for all
sorts of problems whether many of which
around substance abuse but some not even
being able to budget to pay their rent
they couldn't get jobs they couldn't
keep jobs um they couldn't get
unemployment compensation because they'd
get fired from jobs they couldn't get
local welfare assistance because they
couldn't deal with all the
bureaucracy uh many were deest domestic
violence victims already in their young
lives um a number of uh young pregnant
women with nowhere to go
uh and people who got kicked out young
people who got kicked out of
conventional shelters because they're
really no good places for young people
um all of these people uh could benefit
enormously from the services that are
offered uh by the shelter uh and I'll
just add one other thing I think to the
extent that they there were certain
services available to them other than
housing the fact that they're um not
offered by the state is really helpful
and encouraging to people who have grown
up to be very reluctant and wary of the
state so I think
that there's not just a shelter the
programs here are just so essential to
getting people uh moving on the right
track towards successful independent
living and I just urge your support and
that's it thank you thank you Mr Barry
okay I don't see any questions all right
next we
have
ohes this is to you Mr chair and maybe
to the folks in the in the audience uh
in in the interest of time if if if
folks really feel compelled to testify
today then U they should but uh since
division 3 is going to hear this and
have a whole session on this uh the like
kacha Fox U would be welcome welcome to
come to division 3 and spend lots of
time with us I'm just trying to find a
Nami thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the opportunity to
testify today I will be brief and just
uh summarize my written testimony uh for
the record my name is Sam Hawkins I'm
the public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy on behalf of Nami New Hampshire
I'm here today to speak in support of
House Bill
519 in relation to the Waypoint Youth
and Young Adult shelter uh I want to
emphasize the relationship between
housing stability and good mental health
as a critical social determinant of
Health uh stable housing
is an important protective factor for
the mental health of all people for
those with mental health condition
specifically uh stable housing is an
important tool to Aid in their recovery
further a lack of stable housing can
contribute to stress anxiety other
symptoms of poor mental health and at
the same time a serious mental health
condition can make it harder to get and
maintain housing and we can see the
direct impacts of this as about one in
five individuals experiencing
homelessness in the US have a serious
mental health condition
so for Youth and Young adults
experiencing homelessness in New
Hampshire including those who have a
diagnosed mental health condition way
points emergency homeless shelter is an
invaluable program you've heard the
specific details of what is provided
there so I won't go into that but I did
did just want to again emphasize that
this is a safe space for Youth and Young
adults experiencing homelessness that
connects them to Services tailored to
their needs without this shelter Youth
and Young adults in Manchester and
throughout the state will lose access to
those important Services prep uating
their homelessness and jeopardizing
their mental health and wellness for
those reasons n New Hampshire asks the
committee to vote ought to pass on House
time um all right question here from um
representative hackins Phillips thank
you um thank you for taking my questions
Mr Hawkins
um
my constant question throughout today's
testimony is what happens when these
shelters close and I think that question
is particularly important for the Mental
Health Community could you elaborate to
the members of our committee what will
happen to the youth struggling with
mental um crises um who are currently
served by the shelter and Resource
Center if it were to close absolutely I
appreciate your question so obviously
they will lose access to the services
provided directly by the shelter um so
they will lose access to those Case
Management Services they'll lose access
to the safe space the social
opportunities that are provided at the
shelter that are good for their mental
health uh at the same time we know
without housing it is hard to maintain
treatment it is hard to maintain
medication if you're having if you are
on medication uh we know that um if you
are experiencing homelessness and you
have a mental health condition you may
be more likely to be hospitalized you
may be more likely to have interactions
with the criminal justice system and
that is all what we are very concerned
about what this uh if this shelter is to
go
away one followup thank you um thank you
for that explanation and I'm
specifically concerned about um the men
um mental health institutional support
that would be required to pick up the
slack in this instant do you know what
our state offers currently for youth um
who are struggling with mental health
crises that do not have opportunities at
the shelter now where do they go uh that
I appreciate the followup that is a a
large question obviously there are a lot
of services available throughout the
state I think our largest concern uh
would be the escalation of what services
they are pushed into should their mental
health condition progress become more
severe they are pushed into more
restrictive forms of care rather than
the community community based care that
they may access at lower levels of
Acuity um would be our main
concern right thank you Mr Haw thank you
thank you Mr chair I will also be uh
exceptionally brief I just want to uh
for the record my name is Emma savini I
am the children's Behavioral Health
policy coordinator at new Futures new
Futures is here in strong support of
House Bill 519 um specifically because
it would help mitigate adverse childhood
experiences which can be associated with
uh poor health and mental health
outcomes adverse childhood experiences
or Aces have severe consequences during
and throughout adulthood um Aces have
been linked to things such as mental
illness substance misuse um health
concerns such as chronic uh back pain
heart problems um
diabetes and have long-term
consequences when um a young person or
youth experiences
homelessness that housing instability is
just one ace but can contribute to other
Aces as well um youth youth experiencing
homelessness are also more more likely
to have caregivers who are experiencing
mental illness which is another Ace um
or um have caregivers who are
experiencing substance use disorder um
which is also an
ace um further the effect of poverty and
instable housing due to Poverty is um a
compounding impact has a compounding
impact on Aces um and in New Hampshire
youth ages 18 to 24 11% of them lived in
poverty in
2023 um the good news is that ases are
not Resolute so there are mitigating
factors and protective factors such as
provision of stable housing that can
help mitigate those long-term and really
dangerous Health consequences from Aces
um I want to underscore how important
the Waypoint shelter is at providing one
of those protected factors by providing
uh stable housing to Children um Youth
and Young adults in our
community um without the Waypoint
shelter New Futures concern is that
these Aces will continue to compound
resulting in longer term more dangerous
Health consequences which are both
dangerous to the individual but costly
to our state um for those reasons new
Futures urges this uh body to vote uh
ought to pass on house built 519 and I'm
don't see any thank you very much for
coming and um does the department want
to wait for division 3 or come speak now
Fox good afternoon for the record I'm
Kati Fox I'm the director of the
division for Behavioral Health and I do
not want to be the person who drags this
out so that I think the worst people
think about is after lunch before lunch
is much worse so I will um just let you
know that the department is in support
of this bill and I have noted the
questions that um will certainly be
addressed in division 3 and I all um
just as a a preview to that um we want
you to understand where this fits in our
um system and where it fits for our
mission zero which is to reduce the um
um the Ed boarding the emergency
department boarding of individuals in
need of a psychiatric bed um and where
that fits in in our um Mission zero work
and also in our children's system of
care so we can talk more about it on
Tuesday at 11: uh and I look forward to
that and if there are additional
questions be happy to be prepared to um
Tuesday I don't see any hands so we will
close the public hearing on 519 after we
sheets thank
you all right I see one two three four
five six all in favor of those uh it
looks like two are are new Maybe
all right so we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 59 I know division
one we're meeting next Wednesday at um
9: I apologize and uh representative
Edwards are you
meeting um we we have a caucus scheduled
at 1:00 and I propose we move it to like
1:10 so people can stretch their legs
and maybe grab some